[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le journal
de tv 60 18 26 minutes pour résumer
l'actualité locale tout de suite les
titres de ce mercredi 9 octobre
thales recrute ses futurs collaborateurs
en afterwork le site d'elancourt
organiser cet événement hier au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 450 postes
sont à pourvoir dans le groupe qui
produit notamment plusieurs systèmes
installés sur le rafale 1,2 million le
nombre de personnes concernées par le
mal logement en ile-de-france région
pourtant la plus riche de l'hexagone la
fondation abbé-pierre s'alarme dans son
dernier rapport publié cette semaine les
précisions à suivre et puis c'est dans
trois jours le 26e festival de la bd à
buc se déroule samedi et dimanche
elle nous en parlons avec nos invités un
événement vous le verrez qu'ils se
préparent depuis plusieurs semaines au
travers et d'ateliers on débute donc ce
journal avec ce sujet régional ile de
france en pleine crise du logement et
des habitants en plus pauvres la
fondation abbé pierre pousse un cri
d'alarmé de son dans son dernier rapport
publié cette semaine à nos confrères de
via grand paris ont assisté à la
divulgation de ce document regarder le
mal logement
un phénomène qui touche plus que jamais
l'île de france dans son rapport annuel
la fondation abbé-pierre alerte 1,2
million de franciliens sont concernés
c'est environ un tiers des mal logés de
france et vous avez les formes les plus
sévères de mal logement s'est déjà
toutes ces personnes qui n'ont pas de
logement qui sont à la rue qui sent
moins bilingues line qui sont aussi
hébergés chez des tiers
après vous avez des milliers de
personnes qui sont dans des logements
très dégradé et qui vivent dans des
conditions déplorables notamment dans le
parc privé avec des taux d'effort très
important le prix moyen des loyers
explosent dans le privé il est de 19 4
euros le mètre carré contre 12,8
ailleurs en france c'est plus 52% par
rapport à la moyenne nationale
paris bat des records avec 25,6 euros le
mètre carré
les prix du parc social sont aussi plus
élevés comptez 6 6 euros le mètre carré
contre 5 à 5,9 euros dans les autres
régions de france
face à cette hausse des loyers beaucoup
de locataires ne peuvent plus payer 41 %
des expulsions ont lieu sur le
territoire francilien
on est sur les conditions sur les
difficultés de paiement sur les
procédures d'expulsion qui sont toujours
à un niveau assez fort plus de quarante
mille personnes enfin environ 40000
personnes en situation avec des
décisions de justice pour prononcer
l'expulsion donc c'est des phénomènes
aujourd'hui qui sont toujours très
important aujourd'hui en ile de france
une centaine de communes ne respectent
pas la loi sru loi qui oblige à
construire au moins 25 % de logements
sociaux et pour parler du sujet la
fondation abbé pierre présentera son
éclairage régionales dans plusieurs
villes franciliennes suivi et d'une
table ronde le rendez vous est donné par
exemple at rappelé jeudi à 24 octobre
avec cette question est la haye
dématérialisation est elle un plus pour
l'accès au logement des jeunes
l'événement est dédié à l'innovation
pour l'autonomie des personnes âgées et
handicapées le troisième salon hit
onomie a démarré aujourd'hui au campus
des muros et jusqu'à demain
plus de 100 exposants sont présents sur
place tard top association organisme de
formation pour proposer de nouvelles
solutions sur l'autonomie une vingtaine
d'ateliers de conférences animées par
des experts sont également au programme
le les propos recueillis sur place par
manon par aldo et patrick jacques de
dixmude il ya autonomie a été créée
d'abord on a créé une vie
une vie c'est gérer un peu le centre
entre les entreprises les structures de
formation les patients tels et les
futurs employés et à partir de là à
partir d'une vie on a réfléchi
complètement surtout le problème du
grand âge et tout problème de
l'autonomie et à un moment donné on se
nous sommes dit pourquoi il ya trois ans
n'ouvriront pas un salon de l'autonomie
et notamment avec comment le numérique
pourrait être utile pour les notions de
dépendance et de grand âge mais
l'autonomie des personnes âgées à
mobilité réduite sujet du 7-8 société ce
soir sur tv 78 émission enregistrée
depuis ce salon et ito nomi aux mureaux
c'est après ce journal elles ont triplé
en dix ans les chirurgie de l'obésité
sont passées de 20 milles à 60 mille par
an en france le gouvernement souhaite
mieux encadrer et sécuriser ses
interventions annonce hier de la
ministre de la santé des solidarités
agnès buzyn à l'occasion de la journée
régionale de l'obésité elle a détaillé
sa feuille de route pour contrer la
maladie qui touche en france 8 millions
de personnes
et dès l'an prochain les centres
hospitaliers seront soumis à une
autorisation en basés sur un seuil
d'activité minimale pour pouvoir
pratiquer la chirurgie bariatrique
intégrer aussi davantage les
associations dans le parcours des
patients qui doit être mieux coordonnées
décloisonner écoutez la réaction à ce
propos des poids plume l'une des
associations qui travaillent dans le
département dont notamment à poissy à
saint-germain-en-laye port marly ou
encore trappe
il est vraiment nécessaire de renforcer
cette chirurgie puisque dans certains
établissements
la chirurgie n'est pas du tout cadré on
a des parcours qui sont réduits prend un
exemple on peut se préparer à une
chirurgie ces trois semaines donc ça qui
complètement délirant quand on pense
qu'il est nécessaire de se préparer au
moins six mois qu'est ce que la haute
autorité de santé un geek c'est au moins
six mois de parcours pré opératoire est
bien entendu c'est un suivi avec nous
sommes très heureux que madame bus a
annoncé qu' il fallait que les
associations de patients soit partie
intégrante des parcours de soins et
qu'on est à un réel partenaire avec
l'équipe médicale et paramédicale tout
autour de l'obésité priorité donnée
également aux jeunes et au grand public
au travers d'actions de sensibilisation
et aussi de promotion pour une meilleure
formation des professionnels de santé et
des acteurs de l'obésité pendant que
dassault aviation livré le premier de
ces 36 rafale commandés par l'inde ce
mardi son partenaire à thales organise
un afterwork de recrutement au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
cas lien entre ces deux événements est
bien le site de thalès à elancourt
produit plusieurs systèmes installés sur
le rafale un site qui recrutent
actuellement 450 personnes reportage de
nicolas landry une session de
recrutement au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines c'est l'idée
de l'entreprise thalès implantée à
elancourt 150 candidats ont été conviés
à cet événement
objectif trouver des talents saint
quentinois pour des postes d'ingénieurs
et de techniciens avec un niveau minimum
de bac + 2 on a tout intérêt à favoriser
un bon équilibre entre vie personnelle
familiale et vie professionnelle en
réduisant les temps de trajet et en
apportant des opportunités de carrière
aux ingénieurs et aux techniciens sur le
bassin de saint quentin en yvelines
concevoir le cerveau du rafale c'est la
principale activité du site thalès
d'elancourt des radars des équipements
d'information d'écouté de guerre
électronique et des systèmes optroniques
plusieurs dispositifs pensée est
fabriqué à saint quentin en yvelines
ses conceptions en fait ali est
énormément d'expertisé donc à la fois de
la mécanique de l'électronique de
l'informatique et du logiciel qui sont
en fait maîtrisé par très peu de pays
dans le monde
il ya évidemment un aspect de
compétences techniques mais au delà ce
qu'on recherche c'est des profils cd
caractère c'est des savoir être
nous préparons le futur du rafale et les
systèmes complexes de demain qui ne
seront pas limités juste à quelques
aeronet mais du système de systèmes et
travailler aux architectures de demain
est un enjeu aussi importante le site
thalès d'elancourt propose actuellement
450 contrats à durée indéterminée
le territoire rambolitains expérimente
en ce moment en tornado un projet du
véhicule autonome en zone rurale menée
depuis deux ans hier mardi à la
troisième phase de ce test se déroulait
à gaz rend la première fois sur voies
ouvertes en pleine circulation entre la
gare de la commune et la zone
commerciale de bel-air expérimentation
menée par l'agglomération rambouillet
territoire et le groupe renault au
travers de sa voiture zoé les interviews
sont collectées par manou varaldo
tornado c'est pour ceux qui s'en
souviennent le cheval 2 euros et qu'on
pouvait siffler et qu'ils venaient
chercher donc euros à ce moment là elle
s'était un peu l'idée au départ c'est de
se dire on allait proposer sur le
territoire une voiture qu'on pourrait
sifflé entre guillemets qui viendraient
chercher l'habitant chez lui pour
l'emmener à un point b du territoire on
y est presque
voilà donc on a travaillé que nos
partenaires et cette expérimentation
tête depuis deux ans maintenant et se
terminera en juin 2020 elle circulera
depuis le centre commercial de carrefour
qui est partenaire également jusqu'à
cette fameuse gare de gaz euros par la
roue du break nous empruntons
aujourd'hui on va mettre des capteurs
qui vont percevoir l'environnement
les capteurs qui vont permettre à la
voiture de se localiser sur la route et
des software qui vont me permettre de
prendre la bonne décision au vu de son
environnement
un mot de politique avec les élections
municipales en vue c'est en mars 2020 à
guyancourt le parti présidentiel de la
république en marche a investi un
candidat grégory pape formation de 40
ans conduira la liste nouvel élan à
guyancourt il est l'animateur du comité
local de l air em parmi ses soutiens
locaux robert cadalbert l'ancien
président de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines entre 1998 et
2000 14 4 listes sont d'ores et déjà en
lice à guyancourt celle du maire sortant
françois morton est de rodolphe baril et
de l'ancien de l'initiative citoyenne
décidons ensemble à guyancourt donc le
candidat n'est pas encore connue
[Musique]
à buc la 26e édition du festival dédié à
la bande dessinée se déroulera ce samedi
et dimanche et pour en parler deux
invités jean marc le rudulier bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le maire de vue qui
est bonsoir aïssata mini directrice du
service culturel de la commune de buc
alors pour la deuxième année consécutive
ya un atelier de bd qui était organisé
avec des personnes condamnées et suivie
par la justice dans le cadre de ce
festival qui est organisée à buc et
s'était rock l'auteur des profs qui a
dirigé cette opération devant la caméra
daury les onze la bonne ambiance est au
rendez vous pour cet atelier de bande
dessinée un peu particulier les cinq
participants sont des personnes
condamnées et suivi par le service
pénitentiaire d'insertion et de
probation des yvelines cette opération a
lieu dans le cadre de la 26e édition du
festival de l'udc consacré au neuvième
art but c'est vraiment de travail
ensemble de découvrir une activité qu'on
connaît pas forcément et puis de pouvoir
se dépasser aussi attend la confiance en
soi le dépassement de je connais pas
mais je peux y arriver
les participants ont eu deux jours pour
imaginer une bande dessinée comme
l'année dernière c'est le dessinateur et
rock qui l'on doit notamment la série
les profs qui a conduit cet atelier
c'est un milieu qu'on connaît pas c'est
une type de public qu'on ne connaît pas
non plus parce que nous on fait des
interventions scolaires on va dans les
écoles les médiathèques là c'est
intéressant déjà tragique des adultes ce
que j'avais j'avais fais moi avant lundi
dernier
ce que je trouve presque chacun
s'entraide chaque participant donne un
coup de main sur le dessin de l'autre
pour ce petit groupe placés sous main de
justice cette activité a lieu dans le
cadre d'un module de réinsertion je
dessine énormément oui j'adore le dessin
donc tout ce qui est activités manuelles
au cinoche j'adore ça elle prend son
temps pour nous expliquer les buzz les
conseils comment on peut faire extraire
j'ai eu un prof avec été excellents
franchement j'ai passé un agréable
moment
on m'avait des conseils pour le font
pour faire plus ce terreau liège pour
faire plus de la distance
toutes les oeuvres vont être réunies et
seront exposés lors de la 26e édition du
festival de la bd à buc ateliers dans le
cadre de ce festival de la bande
dessinée au programme ce week-end donc à
buc avec ce volet pédagogique social
aussi qui est développé depuis deux ans
jean marc le rudulier avec ses ateliers
avec les personnes condamnées ça c'est
important développé sujet on verra tout
à l'heure un autre aspect un travail
mené avec les collégiens mais voilà de
développer cet axe pédagogique
je crois que c'est un acte pédagogique
prioritaire qu'il fallait il faut il
faut montrer à ses pairs ça ces
personnes empêchées si vous voulez ce
que c'est et est rentré par l'intérieur
rentrée avec un auteur pour essayer de
décortiquer une bd parce que une bd bas
on la lit mais on ne sait pas tout ce
qui s'est passé avant je crois que là
ils ont vu ils on y voit le travail
qu'il faut faire et qu'il faut réaliser
pour atteindre l'objectif final qui est
quand même la réalisation d'une bd ou la
réalisation d'une fresque
il sera exposé effectivement lors du 26e
festival de bd et ça permet de lancer le
festival quelques semaines avant une
préparation d'e-sata mini de longue
haleine voilà ça fait plusieurs semaines
que vous travaillez sur cet événement
qui est annuel on travaille quasiment
toute l'année déjà pour recruter les
auteurs pour choisir les auteurs pour
les convaincre de venir
c'est toujours pas facile pas séparés
il faut aussi on a une cinquantaine
d'auteurs qu'il faut convaincre de venir
au festival bd et viennent avec plaisir
on les remercie d'ailleurs
et donc c'est un travail oui assez c'est
assez long mais c'est que du bonheur
hees a d'ores et déjà démarré puisque
cette semaine ni à des séances de
dédicaces qui est organisée aujourd'hui
en ad'autres vendredi avant cela les
festivals plusieurs dédicaces sont
organisés un petit peu partout sur le
territoire et donc l'idée c'est aussi
d'amener fédérer vers le festival à
travers ces de délocaliser aussi le
festival est d'aller le faire découvrir
ailleurs que dans duke et ça fait 26 ans
qu'il existe à buc bucs et son château
qui est l'un des théâtres de l'album sos
météores de blake et mortimer on est
vraiment dans une commune de bd-fil son
manque le rudulier on est dans une
commune de bd-fil laurie jeu mais vous
êtes amateur de bd alors j'ai découvert
la bd grâce au festival de la bd
j'étais amateur de bd comme tous les
enfants j'ai lu les tintinger lui les
astérix mais j'étais pas rentrer dans ce
détail parce que vraiment il ya une
multitude de péter qui est présente et
je crois que j'y suis rentré par sont
poussés par le festival
et puis quand on arrive au 26e alors là
on est complètement bédéphiles est-ce
qu'on sent une notoriété monte d'année
en année je crois que les nanas vous
aviez est obligé d'installer des tentes
en plus du château pour accueillir les
auteurs étudiants le public ça fait ça
fait déjà deux années ou trois années
qu'on installe des tentes
on a commencé au centre culturel c'était
trop petit on est montée au château
c'est devenu trop petit on met des
tentes
ça va devenir trop petit peut-être un
jour j'en sais rien mais pour l'instant
c'est vrai que ça nous donne une belle
surface tous péri dernière on avait plus
de 1000 m² accessible à tous pour la bd
pardon de la fiche que l'on va avoir que
l'on a sûrement dû voir s'afficher une
affiche dessinée par marc hardy qui met
en scène son personnage de pierre
tombale devant les lézards câble de but
qui est un dénominateur commun que l'on
voit sur les affiches chaque année
toutes les affiches en fait
font référence aux arcades qui est
l'emblème de la ville mais après
l'artiste a vraiment carte blanche pour
la seule la seule demande s'est vraiment
les arcades de but pour le fil
conducteur va dire alors si on parle des
auteurs des dessinateurs qui sont
présents il y en a une cinquantaine
cette année quelle est l'idée est ce que
c'est de proposer des auteurs à une avec
une grande notoriété aussi des auteurs
qui ont du talent qui sont moins connus
tout est dans l'équilibré en fait l'idée
c'est vraiment d'avoir un plateau assez
représentatif aussi de la population
qu'on accueille puisque l'idée c'est
aussi d'accueillir aussi bien les les
mordus de bd que les familles que le
jeune public et donc l'idée c'est
d'offrir un plateau je dirais équilibré
pour que toute personne qui puisse venir
au festival puisse y trouver aussi sa
place mais aussi on a aussi des auteurs
qu'on encourage c'est aussi le rôle de
ce festival c'est aussi de lancer des
gens donc on est vraiment dans cette
dans cette équation qualité mais en même
temps ouverture les parmi eux il y aura
des collégiens deux établissements de
plaisir et d'orge russes ont participé à
un atelier encadré par le dessinateur
bucquoy marc védrines mélanie poquet
pour le sujet c'est l'aboutissement de
huit mois de travail ces collégiens sont
devenus le temps d'une année scolaire
scénariste et dessinateur de bandes
dessinées
j'ai déjà envie depuis longtemps de
faire un métier
dans le dessin donc bah c'est un tout
petit plus c'est un projet en groupe ça
lui permettait de plus participé et puis
tout le monde peut y participer il
fallait pas connaître une réponse vous
proposer nos idées et c'était vraiment
bien le story board ce serait sympa à
faire en classe avec une subvention
parce que et toutes les idées qui
s'entrechoquaient c'était sympa du coup
de voir les plans ces défis au tableau
un travail réalisé en classe dans deux
établissements yves binois blaise pascal
de plaisir et georges pompidou à orgerus
97 élèves ont planché sur le thème du
fantastique en cours de français et
d'arts plastiques spectre avais tu sais
que ça les a soudés
ça a permis aux classes d'être vraiment
avoir une cohésion dynamique
intéressante après il ya des élèves qui
ont des talents naturels pour le dessin
qui se sont évidemment très épanouie
dans le
dans ce projet le cul rencontre a été
plus en difficulté mais qui n'ont pas
pour autant été laissé sur le bord du
chemin
le projet a été pensé par la ville de
buc est soutenu par le département des
yvelines
les quatre classes ont été encadrés par
un auteur reconnu marc védrines auteurs
d'islandia forces spéciales quand on ne
met pas du mime du métier réalise pas à
quel point
réaliser une bande dessinée ça demande
beaucoup de rigueur beaucoup de travail
et on recherche de documentation de
costumes et des histoires qui sont
moment qui se passe en 1870 il faut
faire des recherche de décors de
costumes tout ça comme leurs illustres
aînés ces apprentis bédéiste exposeront
voir dédicaceront leurs créations lors
du festival qui se tient les 12 et 13
octobre
on voit ce travail voilà cette bd qui
donc fini ce travail un des collégiens
vous le disais tout à l'heure je marque
le rudulier le moment où vous remettez
cette bande dessinée aux collégiens
c'est quelque chose de ces quelque chose
à un moment inoubliable
c'est pour eux je pense que pour eux
c'est inoubliable on voit on voit
s'ouvrir les yeux parce que en fait ils
ont travaillé sur les planches ils ont
dessiné mais ils n'ont pas vu le
l'aboutissement et sa l'aboutissement
je crois que ça a été vraiment pour pour
tous les enfants qui étaient là pour
tous les collégiens pardon parce que
plus d offre pour tous les collégiens
c'est vraiment un moment de bonheur donc
à travail mené avec les scolaires on
arrive dans la dernière minute de cet
entretien pour présenter le programme il
y aura de la dédicace des rencontres des
expositions sur sept ce festival c'est
un festival qui a trois axes un volet
donc le culturel via les dédicaces et la
rencontre avec les auteurs un volet
pédagogique avec le travail qui a été
fait avec les enfants les jeunes
les gens du spip un volet ou ici
patrimoniale puisque l'idée c'est de
présenter aussi le château avec son
histoire et donc il y en a un petit peu
pour tout le monde un programme plutôt
riche avec la présence des associations
des centres de loisirs toutes les forces
locales qui viennent et qu'ils rentrent
dans cette thématique qu'est la bd et
qui offre en tout cas aux visiteurs une
journée formidable
tout est prêt pour samedi et dimanche
complet sur le site qui s'affiche en bas
de l'écran merci j'en ai plus rudes
ollier maire de but qui a uni sa taille
mini crise du service culturel de cette
commune 26e festival de la bd de buc
c'est à samedi et dimanche rendez vous
de 10 heures à 18 heures l'entrée est
gratuite
comme tous les mercredis petit tour dans
les salles de cinéma de notre territoire
ce soir direction l'ugc ciné skywest à
saint quentin en yvelines avec à la
fiche joker de todd phillips les
origines de l'ennemi juré de batman lion
d'or de la dernière mostra de venise
quant à penser le public aurait liron et
mélanie poké sont allés recueillir vos
impressions
[Musique]
maîtres du rire et de la joie dans ce
monde
à rethel
rien à voir avec les films de super
héros habituels où ça explose dans tous
les sens où tout le monde est super
génial c'est plutôt le côté
psychologique qui change pas mal des
films habituel qui ont pas vraiment de
fond et c'est très intéressant
les images étaient très symétrique du
coup ça nous mettait à l'aise et du coup
c'est vraiment un contraste avec le jeu
d'acteur qui était très perturbant très
oppressant même le côté psychologique
est vraiment très frappant du du
personnage et l'histoire et on comprend
mieux aussi les origines de ce
personnage et on comprend mieux aussi
les origines de batman
les images le jeu d'acteur incroyable
mal à l'aise avec le corps qu'il a faim
c'est vraiment incroyable ce que ce
qu'il a réussi à faire c'est la manière
dont ces tournées la manière dont ces
films est vraiment concentré sur le
personnage
sa famille s'est enfin sa maman etc sauf
que ça change un peu la façon dont on
peut voir le joker aussi quoi c'était
vraiment profond profond de nos mondes
noirs et ça m'a touché dans un livre que
c'est la première fois que j'ai regardé
un film ça m'a donné son sentiment avant
je me disais que la vie était une
tragédie
je m'en rends compte
[Musique]
que c'est une prime et d
joker donc l affiche d aujourd'hui dans
vos cinémas cette action à présent au
parc naturel régional de la haute vallée
de chevreuse qui s'est déroulée cet été
de nombreuses oiseaux ont été
répertoriés au cours d'une opération de
comptage au sein du site natura 2000
massif de rambouillet et ont participé
huit associations naturalistes
retour sur cette opération avec
gwenaëlle saintilan reconnaissez-vous ce
bruit si particulier chants cris ou
battement d'aile c'est l'engoulevent
d'europe chaque soir pendant une semaine
75 personnes ont pu participer au
recensement de cette espèce
chaque groupe était envoyé sur des
points d coûte différents à partir de
bullion
un inventaire organisée par l'office
national des forêts et le parc naturel
de chevreuse au sein du massif de
rambouillet huit associations
naturalistes des particuliers ainsi que
des membres du parc naturel de chevreuse
et de l'eau à nef se sont rassemblés à
partir de 21h pour participer à ce
projet environnemental
l'objectif est de retranscrire tout ce
qu on va observer par rapport à chaque
site d' écoute
il s'agit de noter tous les oiseaux
chanteurs entendu et les oiseaux
observés la particularité c'est un
oiseau crépusculaire qui a donc une
activité à la tombée du jour
notre groupe s'est rendu au bois de
rochefort espaces naturels sensibles du
département des yvelines
trois points des coûte quelques minutes
de marche
c'est le moment d'ouvrir grand ses
oreilles et d'être à l'affût de ce cri
surprenant
l'engoulevent d'europe en fait ils
utilisent des zones
delande nom de naturel ou même des
landes
ça peut être des jeunes boisement
forestiers sont des zones sableuses
23h30 la période de chasse de cet oiseau
est terminée il est temps de rentrer et
de comparer les résultats trouvés bilan
de ces cinq soirées une centaine de
points d'écouté échantillonnée près de
150 oiseaux vu ou entendu
essentiellement des mâles mais aussi des
poussins mêmes 1,9 couvé par une femelle
pour les organisateurs ce comptage a eu
beaucoup de succès pour les participants
c'était une rencontre avec un oiseau
méconnu du grand public et la découverte
de son milieu de vie fragile mais une
question demeure pourquoi ce nom et bien
c'est un insectivores qui chassent en
volant avec la bouche grande ouverte
d'où son nom l'engoulevent il avale le
vent et du sport pour terminer là mundi
open de france se déroulera vous le
savez du 17 au 20 octobre golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines une date
inhabituels attribué par l'european tour
l'organisateur mais cela va d'ores et
déjà changé le tournoi va retrouver la
période estivale dès 2020 est le
rendez-vous sera programmé du 2 au 5
juillet une bonne nouvelle selon le
directeur technique national christophe
muniesa
joint par michael et demi d'euros on a
travaillé avec le tour européen pour
faire en sorte que l'open de france
retrouve une date plus clémente dans le
calendrier et on est effectivement ravis
que dès 2001 l'open se déroule de
nouveau fin juin début juillet ça nous
semble date plus propice pour attirer
mais voilà c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de l'avoir suivi retour dès demain
pour une nouvelle édition d'information
locale belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]